Just these I don't want the others.
Come on man, I shlepped these all the way here.
There's people waiting.
You know you don't have to be so disrespectful. You've actually carried my books here.
And you are?
Lee Israel.
Oh, we have copies of your latest work right over there
Nobody is going to pay for the writer Lee Israel right now.
I'm months behind in my rent and my cat is sick. It's 4:00 in the afternoon, and you're drunk.
I'm hardly drunk.
Creed, top her off.
My suggestion to you is you go out there, and you find another way to make a living
I recently found this delightful signed letter.
Fanny Brice. One of my favorites. I could give you 75.
oh.
I could give more for better content. It's a bit bland is all
Yeah, I can definitely get a lot worth this one. I mean the PS makes it priceless.
Quite by accident I find myself in a rather criminal position.
What criminal activity could possibly involve except a crime of fashion of coarse.
I'm embellishing
literary letters by prominent writers.
I love his writing.
particularly clever. Don't you think?
Caustic wit.
This is quite something. These are wonderful.
I thought so too.
Name your price.
You are looking at one month's rent
What are we going to do? gamble? shop? drink?
[beep] Ms. Israel, I have a couple questions regarding the last letter I purchased.
Uh oh.
What seems to be the problem?
People are on alert. Your name's been put on a list a list.
On a list?
Their literary treasures. One of a kind. It's my writing!
You're impersonating other people. Nobody's buying Lee Israel letters.
There have been some forgeries going around. -Do you think it's real? -Looks that way. -Good.
You're stealing from me? -Come on. -
Get out of my house.
I was supposed to be something more than this.
We're probably looking at some time behind bars .
What?
I can't say that I regret any of my actions.
In many ways, this has been the best time of my life.
You